este es un pequeño resumen si tomamos a
los habitantes de cierta especie que
comparten la misma área a eso le
llamamos población población y todos los
organismos en esta población en
particular serán habitantes de la misma
especie y podría haber otros habitantes
de esa especie que no se encuentren en
la misma área y por lo tanto no son
habitantes de esta población en
particular y bueno
generalmente en una sola área no existe
una sola especie así que a esta le
llamaremos población 1 y podríamos tener
otras poblaciones de diferentes especies
entonces esta es otra especie y todos
ellos habitan en la misma área esta es
nuestra población
población 2 y podemos tener más
poblaciones pero si tomamos todas las
poblaciones de un área en particular
aunque claro hay flexibilidad respecto a
cómo definen esa área o región si
juntamos esas poblaciones
es decir si juntamos a todos los seres
vivos que habitan en una cierta área a
eso lo conocemos como comunidad
comunidad de poblaciones ahora la
comunidad solamente consiste en seres
vivos es decir los factores bióticos lo
escribiré
bióticos
se refiere a los seres vivos pero si
además de los seres vivos también
queremos tomar en cuenta a los no vivos
que se encuentran en esta región vamos a
escribir factores abióticos
a bióticos también tomamos en cuenta a
los factores abióticos entonces todos
comparten la misma región y eso es
flexible respecto a cómo definen esa
región pero si juntamos a todos entonces
tenemos nuestro ecosistema y el
ecosistema puede ser una región pequeña
o muy grande que consiste en todos los
seres vivos los factores bióticos y los
seres inertes los factores abióticos
entonces de lo que hablaremos en este
vídeo es justamente de los tipos de
ecosistemas que existen pensemos un poco
en eso pero también vamos a empezar a
ver cómo los diferentes factores
interactúan entre ellos cómo es que
existe la conservación de la materia en
un ecosistema pues la materia pasa de
una forma a otra y también tenemos el
flujo de energía la energía entra a un
ecosistema en forma de luz y esa energía
se transfiere de un organismo a otro
incluso algunas veces a los seres
inertes y eventualmente se transforma en
calor ahora si hablamos de los
diferentes tipos de ecosistemas existe
muchísima variedad por ejemplo aquí
tenemos una fotografía de una piscina de
marea en california y en una piscina de
marea podemos considerar tanto a los
factores abióticos como el agua y la
roca como a los factores bióticos como
la estrella de mar las anémonas y todo
lo demás que esté viviendo aquí entonces
si combinamos todo eso tenemos un
ecosistema incluso podemos decir que
toda la playa es un ecosistema o que
toda la región es un ecosistema todo
depende de qué tanto queramos acercarnos
o alejarnos y por ejemplo si nos
alejamos aquí podemos ver esta selva el
amazon es y podemos considerar a toda la
selva como un ecosistema o tal vez sólo
queramos estudiar lo que está pasando en
esta región y a eso también lo podemos
siderar ecosistema o podemos estudiar lo
que ocurre únicamente en el río o
únicamente en una parte del río y como
pueden darse cuenta estoy hablando de
algunos ecosistemas que están en la
tierra y otros que están en el agua esa
es una forma general de clasificar los
podemos tener ecosistemas terrestres
o en el agua es decir acuáticos y dentro
de los acuáticos podemos tener
ecosistemas en agua salada o en agua
parcialmente salada a los que llamamos
marinos los ecosistemas marinos
principales son los océanos y después
tenemos a los ecosistemas de agua dulce
por ejemplo si nos encontramos al norte
del amazon es hay agua dulce entonces
tenemos agua dulce es decir agua que no
es salada y aunque parece que los ríos
son grandes y hay muchísima agua dulce a
nuestro alrededor que es el agua que
necesitamos para vivir la mayoría de los
ecosistemas acuáticos son marinos no
involucran agua dulce ahora estos son
sólo algunos ejemplos e incluso tenemos
a nuestro cuerpo podemos ver a nuestro
cuerpo como un gran ecosistema o podemos
ver partes de nuestro cuerpo como
diferentes ecosistemas
podemos observar únicamente una fracción
por ejemplo supongamos que está
es mi mano y podemos analizar solamente
esta parte y considerarla un ecosistema
podemos pensar en las diferentes
bacterias que existen ahí o en los
diferentes tipos de microorganismos que
hay y cómo interactúan con cosas inertes
como el aire podemos analizar cómo
interactúa con los aceites de nuestra
piel o con las células muertas y también
cómo interactúa con las células vivas de
la piel y con el resto de nosotros y
bueno cómo estamos enfocados en cómo
clasificar a los ecosistemas algo que
generalmente se hace es clasificar a los
ecosistemas terrestres en varias
categorías miren aquí tenemos una imagen
que muestra los principales tipos de
ecosistemas terrestres en nuestro
planeta y en donde los podemos encontrar
y a todos estos diferentes tipos de
ecosistemas terrestres se les conoce
como biomas
dio más y como podemos ver en este mapa
aquí encontramos el bosque tropical que
es donde se encuentra la selva del
amazonas pero también lo encontramos en
áfrica y en el sudeste asiático y
también lo encontramos en centroamérica
y parte de norteamérica después tenemos
los bosques boreales que los encontramos
al norte y bueno también existen la
sabana el desierto la tundra el hielo
polar el chaparral el bosque templado y
los pastizales templados y todos estos
nos ayudan a entender cuáles son los
diferentes tipos de ecosistemas que
encontramos en esas regiones y
generalmente están determinados por la
temperatura la humedad el clima el
terreno y los tipos de minerales que se
encuentran ahí todo eso es un buen
indicador que nos ayuda a saber cómo es
esa región y qué tipo de vida habita ahí
pero aún con todo esto existe mucha
variedad por ejemplo el desierto de
sonora que se encuentra por aquí al
suroeste de los estados unidos y al
noroeste de méxico
este es un desierto pero existen otros
desiertos en el resto del planeta que
aunque pueden ser muy parecidos no
tienen exactamente el mismo clima o
exactamente los mismos factores
abióticos o los mismos factores bióticos
por ejemplo les voy a enseñar unas
fotografías del desierto de sonora y del
desierto rocoso que se encuentra en la
isla de boavista boavista se encuentra
por aquí aunque no podemos verla en este
mapa pero es una isla muy pequeña en la
costa de áfrica y miren cómo podemos ver
en estas fotografías no tenemos que ser
expertos para reconocer que ok los dos
son desiertos los dos se ven secos no
hay mucha agua por aquí pero también son
diferentes
miren en el desierto de sonora hay un
poco más de vida que
en el desierto rocoso que vemos aquí por
eso se llama así desierto rocoso o
desierto pedregoso porque a simple vista
parece que todo lo que existe son
piedras
entonces las biomas son una forma
aproximada de clasificar a los
ecosistemas terrestres pero incluso dos
ecosistemas que están categorizados
dentro de un mismo tipo de bioma pueden
ser muy diferentes